[Musique]
à quelques jours du mercato estival et
après avoir signé pour deux ans
supplémentaires avec le psg qui viennent
m apéro devient le joueur le plus cher
du monde c'est pas de doute à ce sujet
évaluée à 200 6 millions d'euros
l'observatoire du football c ies à
classer l'attaquant de paris en tête du
classement des valeurs de transfert je
pense que mon historique si elle n'est
pas terminée je pense que j'ai des beaux
chapitres encore à écrire et cgt rial et
du real de madrid vinisud junior et le
joueur de manchester city erling allende
bref vous l'avez compris il faudra
désormais crash est le porte monnaie
pour s'offrir les services du joueur
français amap est un meilleur joueur du
monde alors qui n aiment d'apéro devient
le joueur le plus cher du monde êtes
vous choqué par le montant
[Applaudissements]
c'est le cas des panneaux des petits
panneaux
jamais le débat jamais voilà sur les
footballeurs est-ce que c'est trop
l'argent oui c'est beaucoup d'argent est
ce trop non alors il ya deux personnes
qui sont choqués madame oui
économiquement je ne suis pas choqué
parce qu'il est vous allez me dire qu'il
rapporte à bas beaucoup plus et tout ça
humainement excusez moi je resterai
choqué ça va être très démago mais quand
d'une infirmière gagne 2000 euros que
personne au monde ne méritent ces sommes
même le plus grand joueur du monde
l'argentin
économique ça ne me choque pas
cris ne les vole pas je suis tout à fait
d'accord et on me les offrir est
ce que je serai
bien débuté
c'est même souvent je me précisent ses
206 millions nets d'impôts
jaoui mais bien sûr samedi le club ça me
vient c'est bien pour la fra oui le psg
verse en fait verse aussi 200 millions à
l'état français mais oui non terme il y
aura la signature ben oui les primes de
sponsors les primes de match mais tant
mieux parce qu'il va dépenser le pognon
et s'il est payé 206 c'est qui la
rapporte oui c'est vrai mais c'est celle
du business à économique meilleure et ce
qui est fantastique quand même c'est que
juste avant je lui dis nomi fund elle
dit c'est pas normal que quelqu'un c'est
son choix mais je dis si toi tu prends
206 alias et papa
[Applaudissements]
ces avides d'aventurés comme alors pour
voir les dix meilleurs footballeurs payé
au monde attention c'est pas son salaire
c'est sa valeur sur le marché un hasard
entre saleh et sa valeur sur le marché
savez-vous m'aurait menti non il vaut
200 millions d'euros tout a été vendu
3,6 tout chez lui six mois j'ai voulu
m'en servir j'ai millions 5,2 millions
par mois hors sponsors donc ça faisait
20 millions par an ah oui d'accord
d'accord c'est sa valeur sur le marché
des valeurs kiné qui ne sort pas de
nulle part c'est qui rapporte énormément
évidemment en billets en maillot et
c'est donc cesser évidemment vérité
alors l'appétit la nouvelle-zélande est
mieux valorisé
alors le numéro alors il ya quand même
alors que je peux je connais pas
beaucoup des footballeurs distribution
alors alors le dernier set mais encore
être suis je connaissais la paix
alors roumaine rom ndiass manchester 109
millions 110 millions 112 millions 224
et la presse s envole quel pied tout
seuil trash billing and cie joue je suis
là à dortmund c'est ça ouais 133
millions magie quand même quand même 1
500 panneaux à 18 a fait d'oser 105
millions
comprennent bien son salaire annuel sait
combien c'était aux alentours de 20
millions d'euros net élèves je pense
qu'il a pris
1,03 mais là il ya messi année marquent
souvent dans cette liste et six qui sont
extrêmement bien payé aussi la cellule
alors sur le marché s'en va pour un
salaire énorme en angleterre il en avait
marre mais neymar mais je pensais qu'il
était en boîte de nuit
excusez moi je les rumeurs n'ont pas
beaucoup joué j'ai apprise harry n'a pas
beaucoup joué il paraît qu'on voit plus
du côté de l'arc
du côté du parquet ce qui est important
aussi dans le psg sait quelles maps et
français et s'accapare mba fait kiffer
mais il y avait très peu de stars
françaises au psg beaucoup de joueurs
étrangers
l'aïe a le projet de faire venir zidane
également donc c'est important pour le
psg de redevenir aussi un club français
et pas internationale vous avez la
rumeur il paraître ayant signé qui est
enfin c'est pas ce nom il le il devrait
signer zidane de rester au psg pour
entraîner le psg travaille mais vous
avez vu que le président c'en est un peu
mêlé quand il a fait un appel du pied
levé un gros appel du pied
magnéto
j'ai pu parler avec kilian la paix mais
il fait son choix en conscience et c'est
quelqu'un qui est là montrait d'ailleurs
et est très mûr construit sa carrière
son engagement avec beaucoup de sens des
responsabilités
je n'ai pas parlé à zinedine zidane mais
j'ai une immense admiration pour lui le
joueur l'entraîneur et on a très envie
d'avoir un championnat français
un sportif un coach de ce talent qui a
su ramener
trois grandes cool que nous convoitons
beaucoup pour nos clubs donc moi je
souhaite pour le rayonnement du
championnat français pour la france qui
reviennent et qui viennent entraîner un
grand club français
le président le président nous a fait le
job et novozymes
et la maison comme ça il a rien de dire
oui pourquoi pas mais c'est bien c'est
dire c'est alors la question est ce que
c'est le rôle d'un président
par l'équipe de france il peut
effectivement rien appel du pied à
zinedine zidane mail en l'occurrence il
parle du psg bat pas se mêler du psg il
parle pas c'est le président de tous les
clubs de france oui oui garde de grands
étendard français qu'il s'agisse demba
peduzzi
c'est totalement son rôle parce que
alors je moi j'ai lu quelque part et
c'est très simple c'est tellement sage
trou pour macron commencer un mandat
alors que ksm bape et partirait ce
serait comme si on lui avait qu'on avait
acheté quelqu'un avait acheté la tour
eiffel et c'est totalement ça il y a
tellement de questions géopolitiques
commerciales financières sous jacente
qui nous échappe perdre 1 qui anime
batterie ya des lycéens qui sont légion
si on les législatives c'est pas
vraiment pareil fois